hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to doom now we're on
Mars that's not really a relevation
we've been on Mars the entire time we've
been playing but we're on Mars and
that's an important thing to know but we
did just complete that rune thing that I
had to do again because for some reason
the checkpoint system didn't get it to
me so we're about to go onto the surface
of Mars which is more important thing
than I was talking about hey dick bag
get away from me and apparently we're
trying to do something to get a rune or
whatever have you I don't even know what
it would be called is it called a rune
is it called what was it called
hang on I spy with my little eye a lever
Wow Wow I found a secret already I have
no idea what hi
was that the war horn does that mean um
I see I spy with my little eye on Argent
thing garden thing okay so it oh no oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] okay well not what I
wanted
fast [ __ ] god you screamy bastards get
away from me I'm trying to do a thing
here there's something very important up
here that I need to get okay
yep oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay
really anticlimactic for all the effort
that it seems to need shed can I make
that hope oh [ __ ] no I can't well that
didn't go as I'd hoped
that'll ain't exactly the opposite that
I'd hoped I sure hope I don't have to do
the goddamn rune trial again that would
suck but hopefully that's not in
hopefully the thing is still thing yeah
[ __ ] where am I now
oh I know where I am well that rune
better not be there I think it's not
there it's been another day is that
thing still flipped
I can't tell is there uh there a thing
I'm able to see oh okay it might be back
there which means that it's not flipped
I got to go flip it again I'm a
professional switch flipper and they're
really hard to flip Wow alright wait
hang on that's not [ __ ] well I seem to
be making a goddamn fool of myself over
and over again for everybody out there
aren't you glad that I started this
episode with so much vim and vigor and
happiness and suckage have ample amounts
of suck everywhere you go all right
whatever last last time this time with
less stupid because I've got way too
much stupid where the hell do I hear yes
this would be s this would be the proper
answers is yes okay without embarrassing
myself ah titties they're blasting
themselves all over me okay so I'm not
mistaken and if I'm not stupid of which
no one is sure ting about that one okay
hip-hop okay we're fine everything's
fine everything's under percent
hunky-dory [ __ ] I think it's over here
it's usually not too far away from the
thing that you're trying to get so I spy
it I spy it with my little lion oh boy
this isn't like that important but it's
cool
yay I got the Phobos lab Phobos is the
name of one of Mars's moons the other
being damos both of them aren't really
moons in the traditional sense they're
more like celestial satellites which
just means that they're asteroids that
were captured in Mars is gravity in
comparison to our Moon which is formed
very differently the current theory
being that it was formed with another
planetary body impacting with Earth is
much much larger by comparison hello
yeah
Phobos guy see Phobos in the game is
just another another doom like character
but not quite doom guy I don't I don't
know if he has any official lore though
I really don't know man these secrets
aren't really a secrets they're just
right in front of my goddamn face okay
let me suck that power into my body
become a little more possessed by the
devil all right so I've gotten plenty of
ammo I've actually learned that my ammo
situation is it's quite good to be
perfectly honest how do I get down there
how does one do that it was open before
[ __ ]
well Adam sound good Oh okey-dokey then
I'll go in thank you no stop sorry we're
closed
sorry all right where am I now
I want you
okay I'll play out a game you will raagh
the hell am I going oh okay I got it
boy this sure is a non OSHA friendly the
pathway what's over here oh nothing
Oh a lot of nothing I wasted my face
slamming into that stupidness okay what
does that do whoo bye I bet that guy got
sucked up into a whole lot of
nothingness there's a lot of expose
there's a lot of exploding barrels
around here I said the thing that I need
to do avoid and then i standed directly
inside of it that's the kind of keen
strategist I am is I'm not good enough
for grammar okay well I don't understand
what you're wanting from me okay I'm
fine everything's fine it's fine it's
cool it's cool it's fine
understand cool fine fine and cool bruh
oh hello what oh I got the weapons
division is this where there's gonna be
a BFG not really a secret again just a
room that I could have wandered in at
any moment but oh well I'll take your
secret as a secret hi goodbye hi goodbye
okay so that takes care of those guys
one more for the road and there's
something in there
it looks big and shiny if it's a gun I
want it what I think it might be the BFG
hello oh sorry just let me in I'm here -
hello
okay I thought I saw a man cubis over
here oh I did I was 100% right about
what I saw
boy it sure is close words to be playing
around with you
oh that's why it's green and glowy okay
I could chainsaw but that'd be a wasted
chainsaw I'm just gonna shotgun him I'm
not gonna make it Oh [ __ ] shouldn't
been that close to everybody okay please
die please die oh why is this like that
the way that it is thank you what about
those guys they're kind of a demonic
presence don't you think maybe maybe now
depends on what they qualify as a
demonic presence Wow goddamnit I got
your wood stop it stop slapping me sassy
slaps the BFG 9000 advocates witnessed
the BFG 9000 what greater triumph for
the glory of the Ascension could there
be than an entirely new type of weapon
born not only of traditional UAC
technology but by your faith and
dedication to the cause okay remember
how in dead space they wanted an
ascension - it didn't quite work out for
everybody they made a whole moon of
corpses and speaking of moon this moon
was about as big as Earth moon this is
there's no [ __ ] Deimos moon this is
a big honkin moon actually is damos a
smaller one I can't quite remember test
fire okay whew what are we test firing
ah is that what we're talking about when
we're talking about the BFG because I
want me some of that sir Zerbe FG in
here but stick directly into this barrel
haha okay
alright anyway goodbye I need to find
out how to get this thing shut up
[ __ ] there's gotta be a whole bunch
of stations in here station logged that
guy did not have a good time I'll take
this let's take that corpse upper torso
acquired great huh yeah I don't know why
it took that but I got it so yeah I'll
just stuff that in my back pocket where
I did it for later not a hundred percent
sure why okay hello can I have your
bottom tours oh thank you
perfect actually that's oh wow
I never noticed the way the blood kind
of actually sprays on the ground that's
weird Oh theoretical design for the BFG
was performed by R&D advanced research
complex and concept was later given
funding its own problems blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah argent streams that
seek out targets and boils them alive
that's the only line you really need to
know about I'm talking about this gun it
boils your enemies alive
okey-dokey then so again you're talking
up this gun a whole lot how do I get my
hands on it hello this is a secret is
this a secret come on oh come on there's
gotta be look at this look so secret ish
Oh what a bunch of lies what a bag of
ass is that is
hey buddies hello sorry I missed didn't
miss that time not that time either
Oh still not missing how weird boink
okay oh hi um no anything else to do I
guess I can testify er this one kind of
be the same thing huh
okey-dokey then I think the basic gist
of what they're trying to get across is
that this weapon is literally hell
itself oh oh thank you dr. Peters have a
good one oh well oh I was prize pose I
know what I was probably but to climb on
top of the chamber instead of looking
down at the ground like a ninny waiting
to die well that was my bad I apologize
all right let's try that again
uh-huh so far so good
it wasn't activated already that didn't
seem oh oh that would have if I'd have
been standing on that thing I would have
been very scared
well that's instant death huh it's like
them world's most dangerous game of
hopscotch
I wouldn't mind playing but I think I'll
be over here weaponizing demons for a
brighter tomorrow
again that spokesperson is not on our
side
Oh second pass I guess just in case to
make sure they're extra dead how long
are you gonna wait around for this I got
a lot of water to drink by the way BF G
stands for big [ __ ] gun
Oh whoo bye oh wow that was an efficient
slice all righty then I'll take this
thank you very much Howie oh whoops I
guess we're okay so long as me and my
gun are okay I think we belong just fine
for a thing it only has like four shots
so you only use it for the biggest of
the baddies accessed by pressing T use
it to devastate your enemies it has its
own designated button not just a number
holy [ __ ]
it's a big deal all right is there
anything else in here while we're down
here anymore like ammo or something
anything I should know about new oh I
missed that field drone now whatever now
the big deal I'm not gonna worry about
it got other things to worry about
Oh Oh it wanted me to use the BFG there
that would have been an intelligent use
of my time i'ma load that so you guys
don't miss out on it because that would
have been cool
unfortunately I'm stupid and switched
out for my shotgun I don't I'm not under
percent sure why oh well I guess it
didn't want you to see something so cool
too much oh hi everybody go go go
so um word and all these survivors go is
the question did they get out of here
today escape I don't think that everyone
died I'm pretty sure that not everyone
fell victim to the dudes well this is
locked anyway why did I even come over
here so there must be some survivor
somewhere
I mean Hayden it makes sense but
everyone else hi another chance oh my
god Wow
oh it blows basically the principle of
it is is that it blows up everything
everywhere it annihilates everything
I'll save it for now though cuz I don't
want to waste it all I've only got one
shot left but I don't want to waste it I
wouldn't want to do that
we cracked it maybe not direct well what
the [ __ ] is that okay cool I don't know
what it is it's in Randy
but I'm happy about it whoo ah this
would make a lot of sense saving this
quad damage for more what did you shoot
how it's not being such a dick bag okay
anybody anybody else wanna play you do
Oh No well where where where where am I
what the [ __ ] there was no path around
there I thought I knew for sure there
would be something over there well nope
amazing what you can do with the shotgun
Mikey get away oh you didn't run away
fast all right we've got to be something
else here something to give me a
challenge what is this oh that was B F
GM oh cool
oh hey
you know nope nope nope nope nope oh
you're dead okay
boink oh so far so nothing big I don't
know why I need that freaking uh-oh
there's even more BFG ammo man they
really want me to use this BFG don't
they
I'd hate to deprive you guys have
perfect vfg destruction but I really
want to wait until I see something
worthy of quad damaging yeah maybe now
it's good enough well everything's dead
now except for that guy what's that
guy's shield the load of [ __ ] oh you
look like BFG worthy bloated are you
still alive
alright i'm Kuantan doesn't seem like
anything's worth it over here boink by
your feet oh hey how's it going I got
stupid I went for I always go I always
die when I go for these fancy things
like a little beer to the quad man
speaking idiot alright be a little
better than Sam maybe a little bit now
much I don't want to be too much better
I gotta go who through that whole
endeavor again which is stupid but
whatever it is what it is my [ __ ]
face I was standing by an exploding
barrel barrel
okay we're generally back into the
better parts of what we're doing old
[ __ ] that guy I hate you bees
alright times you do this and then times
you do that all you I forgot that you
were a
oh well you did enough so I guess no
one's really worrying about it
Oh time to do this oh you're not you're
not the man Kubis where it's mang Cuba's
first of goddamn thank you mrs. is
where's the bank you buy well there's
100 anyway I guess I don't need to worry
about that thank you thank you for
participating in my little experiment
hello get away get away I said do you do
we hate oh no oh no oh no oh [ __ ] did
Megan wank back daddy that made it that
made it into giblets anybody else want
oh it's a shield guy down there well he
ain't gonna last long cuz I say so
ah [ __ ] you strong ass their years here
specifically your ass that is strong all
right what else we got
nothing okay got them all okay is this
where everyone is are they all dead did
they survive again hello oh my god oh my
god damn it I wasn't ready for this
got it give me warning before you
freakin douche up the place with your
douchiness affairs some out [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you hey ash ah I blew myself up
well I didn't know to be coming around
the corner I would have gotten some
health or something I would have prepped
I thought I was doing didn't have any
goddamn BFG ammo left they didn't leave
me in here
least I wish some I guess I'm chopping
that guy up now it's pretty cool Oh what
the [ __ ] back here [ __ ] you guys you
[ __ ] that's a habit a habit okay I
got it again
um that man that is unfortunate that
that takes so long I mean Mads my fault
for not paying attention as to what I
was supposed to be doing Samet chainsaw
one of these [ __ ]
hello I'm gonna be FG the [ __ ] how the
other one ready who's out hi welcome to
the party hook too late for you oh yes
hey where's the other where's your
friend huh cheese party oh yeah oh no
wow I guess a direct hit from this thing
and killed pretty much anything except a
cyberdemon which I imagine I'm going to
be facing soon I did realize this whole
time that I've been playing I haven't
really you know faced a boss ah I was so
close to the last one I did terribly
this
I didn't terribly yeah laughs now
whatever I did did what I could
I did what I could I couldn't be
expected to do any better okay you're at
the heart of the UAC occult the Lazarus
labs this is where Olivia released
demons from their cells and activate the
Lazarus wave turning UAC personnel into
unwilling possessed you're in search of
her private offices where the helix
stone is stored unlock the secrets of
the sacred artifact to find out how to
shut down the well the argent our source
of energy in hell we're all ready then
the problem means I gotta go back to
Hell at some point and punch it in the
face it's like a punch everything else
in the face that's how I solve all my
problems one reason you might be able to
see something we haven't okay maybe I've
seen it already you don't know that
maybe maybe maybe you know maybe maybe
maybe a little bit something to that did
you oh wait who was there oh it's the
flying heads again they always spook by
gimme gimme gimme gimme
okay so facing into this next area with
a little more professionalism a little
less douching ism mistake that he has
come into a position the demons promised
I his return if he winks it could
jeopardize the entire mission for he is
the only one instead
me are you talking about me you
flatterer oh you know Olivia if you just
wanted to take me on a date you could
have just asked I mean I wouldn't have I
would have said no I I would have a
hundred percent said no I don't care
about kicking ass this doesn't seem like
it was any sort of a secret so why did
no one else in the entire facility know
about this hi what the [ __ ] is going on
with this [ __ ] what happened in this
place who the what this [ __ ] stop it
bye man this is so bizarre like all the
all the faith-based ideas behind this
stuff is is this really interesting I
mean it's been it's been done before who
hello
this isn't gonna work ah there we go
blasted your butt apart okay so let me
just make sure cuz I got the the update
that shows all the items whenever
they're around so I just got to make
sure that I actually go to everything so
it looks like the proper way to go would
be down that hallway and there's nothing
else around here okay so if that is the
case which it might be hang on let me
see something hey there's something down
there how do I get down there probably
by going this way and then going down
and around like the map said it would
but I didn't pay attention to the map
I'm just going on instinct my peer 100%
gamer instinct oh he was probably so
and not so supple
alright oh hey hey let your friend go
why aren't you happy to see me yeah
whatever I guess I can get this thing
going cuz I don't really use much of the
plasma rifle and it does give me a lot
of opportunities yeah I found a secret
mega health thank you
it was something I hey uh huh okay I
remember this from from like one of the
trailers or something it was like on the
steam trailer
I can't remember this area looks
familiar but I can't remember exactly I
think so
yep good bye oh I want to touch this
with my fist oh they are in cages
fascinating fascinating ok so that's
really interesting they've literally did
harvest demons from hell brought them
here and then use them for
experimentation then release them but so
all these demons are here were only here
because hey buddy so all that I mean
what I'm trying to say I'm trying to
think and fight at the same time not
working out too well
friends do things [ __ ] dude play don't
be like that don't be like that
so in the initial invasion of the only
demons were around here unless those
gaping mouth things were actually
helping them infest innate I don't know
I'd anything
again are you Adam okay alright
Oh how do you survive that nonsense
induce bicha lloyd rabbits okay okay so
yeah what I was trying to get at didn't
come through properly was that the the
initial invasion was only demons that
were here or did the demons somehow
figure out a way with which to some and
more demons from hell but that would
mean that individual demons have the
capability of doing that and there's a
lot of hellish runes around here oh look
BFG ammo just lying around in the cells
with them the most secure place to keep
that would be with the demons themselves
is my imagination god damn it
okay so somewhere in here there is some
stuff over there okay so if I go around
and around okay I can do that it's on
the other side over there Broly where I
was hippity hoppity around let me just
grab the rest of the ammo that I can and
then move on I don't use my rockets
enough but frankly I think I'd kill
myself at the rocket Slayer was ever
given an opportunity
this Jessica person cuz the residence I
know would happen to them
the revenants ain't no do too good why
would anybody want to be revenant man
there was a lot of operating under the
improper assumptions around here a lot
of assuming a lot of things about a lot
of people that probably people should
have asked a few more questions for and
not been so faithful but then again it
is a vision
it seems like somewhere there'd be a
secret I know that is a secret
hello I was wondering where you would be
hi I'll take that don't mind me okay
what did I get a research token they're
not the parade your token I need to use
the parade too Toby ah there we go Elite
Guard finally no not dad the Elite Guard
all right
USC employees are advised to comply with
any orders received from an elite guard
their jurisdiction is absolute answering
only to the highest level executives of
the UAC
if an elite guard kindly request that
you accompany them to the Lazarus labs
you will be going to the Lazarus labs
with such powerful capabilities in each
lead guard it was deemed necessary to
haven't plan to kill chip and each
uniform so that they might also be
controlled children uprising occur among
their ranks the kill chip response to a
Lazarus wave signature that can be only
broadcast by Samuel Hayden or Olivia
Pierce ha so that's why they're all dead
but what where did they just find
private nooks and cranny's with which to
masturbate in was that the reason why
they all died and seemingly sporadic
areas what the hell happened and why
would they kill them all it seems like
they would have been very useful in the
event of an invasion much like the one
we find ourselves in
of their influence I was wrong yes you
proved to be weaker than I thought
funny about that a lot of people is that
way man I don't have a lot more things
to go okay Mike I mean I'm not gonna use
it much because I intend to use the
other thing baby
because I want to get the mastery in
that one before I do anything cloaking
um question we're the hello above of
course alrighty then who wants some
anybody anybody wants them anybody at
all
some is available in all quantities
anything okay I heard some rumbling at
the Oh oh no that's nothing I thought
those were holding cells for giant
monsters but apparently I was wrong
brother they go through here yes doink
who needs to grab it oh so gently these
hands weren't built for caressing these
hands were built for punching wait
monsters cyberdemon huh what [ __ ]
thought that cyberdemon cyberdemon the
corax tablets discovered during the UAC
automated survey of 21:43 mentioned an
ancient battle in the titans realm
during the Third Age blah blah blah blah
blah blah piecing the creature back
together wait a minute wait a minute
ancient battle in the Titans realm than
to piece it back together wait a minute
man was that mean the original do
maybe I don't know maybe maybe maybe
maybe maybe there was some weird
temporal thing where when I went to hell
in the original doom there was something
along the lines of going back in time or
time got really weird or or what have
you
whoa something something broke out but I
would hazard a couple guesses something
exploded something a sploded
all right anyway that's interesting
though that's very very engine is big
holy [ __ ] okay so that's where the
entrance to the Wow
what the [ __ ] that's probably the
entrance to the thing but how does one
get to the thing there's quite a gap
there so around here somewhere is a
lever I'm gonna find this lever I'll be
right back okay nevermind I had to look
it up this is not the area where that is
so nevermind we're moving on everybody
carry on with your lives it's not that
big a deal okay so the cyberdemon has
escaped and it's some hi nice tuck and
roll there dickbag how you doing
puppy day I blew his entire back out now
I blew his entire face off I might as
well blow the rest of them maybe hello
nobody left to blow no chair either when
that happens wait
okey-dokey then hey friend hey friend
caboose geek
I saw you how you hit me but I saw you
yeah um all right so we got a couple
ways we could go about this how about
that one I like that option now is my
favorite option
earlier bbbbb about bebeto boo hey I
missed I missed well I missed again [ __ ]
why I keep missing a [ __ ] dude what days
I'll get him oh [ __ ] here we go [ __ ]
exactly what I wanted to do perfect
precisely whoa what the hell happened
here yeah with these guys transformed or
did you experiment on them when they
were fully human you can earn turn that
guy into a frickin lump what the [ __ ]
happened here yeah grody grody alright
hang on I got a check this is a long
hallway that I just went down you're
lucky there's nothing around here
because holy [ __ ] all right
carrying on who's around here uh-huh
stop doing this oh shut up shut up okay
there we go that that's better you
please die you fall over you forget
forget entirely everything you ever
hoped or okay hello hello hello goodbye
all right where am I now
oh I see um yeah
d-man they did a lot of [ __ ] here in the
lassard's labs I gotta admit wink
anybody gonna pop out of these things
should I be worried about a bed's a big
operating table I mean my god you think
someone would have raised one eyebrow
about anything that's happening here no
nothing not not a single concern from
anyone in the peanut gallery I'm going
for the frickin quad damage shield
didn't stand a chance
oh my god anybody else
you all right quad all gone oh one more
left at the party I'm sorry buddy I
didn't mean to do that yeah sorry
okay Matt everybody yeah pretty much
you know those automatic lockdown
systems don't make a lot of sense when
the whole place is filled with demons
anyway even if they are caged up it
seems like a bit of a problem no that
guy's sliced in bits
did I kick it to him did I do that yeah
probably I guys still in one piece
though okay so let's see there anything
over there absolutely not huh but there
is something up above me over here
hello proceed at your own risk open
sealed area huh you know I'm okay with
this doesn't seem so bad for a sealed
area I gotta use those Prater tokens
because I've been I've been hoarding
them non-stop so I gotta use them um
environmental resistance that would be
nice I'm human and that's perfect immune
to explosive barrel damage I love it um
what else could I do though upgrade
system improve the effective power-ups
would be nice speed of certain acts
would be nice which weapons faster very
good grab ledges I guess swap weapon
mods fight yeah that's not exactly the
first this one was okay if the second
one was men's power a damaging blast
wave his release sounds good upon
activating empower up healed oh that
sounds good too I like the sound of that
too soon yeah I would have liked to
spend more on that and less on the
douchey ones that I had before but
whatever beggars can't be choosers not
that I was begging in the first place
but I'm choosing boy thank you
alright what else we got I'll get there
in a second
Mo's well god I really need to upgrade
my armor throw this through there nope
yeah the answer is no my friend
oh I'm in here now I guess this house is
done wow that's what it do poink poink
I already freaking [ __ ] man that
blast wave is really good
nobody overdue
stopped him in his tracks
Wow what the what the brook oh my god I
got destroyed by a hill that isn't oh hi
I needed those all right Wow I needed
that too Wow my lights you knocked him
out well that was weird
uh I don't think that one imp at enough
to be able to knock my socks off so
let's try this again shall we
how one that's not the one I was aiming
for [ __ ] how whatever it's good enough
good I'll take it
ah baggers can't be choosers wherever
that one before okay I'd like to think
that the majority of that was caused by
exploding barrels and not me
that's probably what happened what if I
to guess probably travel probably around
param param param what is this what is
happening here is your secret Aiki
easier something behind here oh hello
there is aa drop down here what do we
get
hi hey how you doing
alright there was something else weird
oh I see one of these is an actual rune
room No
was that not it looks like it oh no that
was the that was the mega hell that was
the big I got it got it that was a big L
got it boink and away we go
wait so are we still in the same map oh
hello
okay all right um bull strange little
little strange I'm beginning to think
that guys not entirely on our side hey
it's a stone
[Music]
here's your authorization
all right fine then [ __ ] you got my
symbol on it apparently Oh No maybe
we'll get to them deeper mystery of why
I'm here
I don't know what this means okay what
about this that's a little grody why is
that stone infested with flesh or why is
that flesh infested with stone who knows
which huh what a bunch of bizarre
artifacts and the old concept of using
hell for science is just really
interesting okay goodness gracious yeah
what else we got here oh it goes down
there's a doom guy up there why is your
doom day over there how the hell would
you get to that guy there's nothing
there there's nothing there
oh no okay so there's something back
here might as well just carry on huh
I feel like I'm being led somewhere whoa
this is a trap I'm gonna bypass it like
a boss all right
who you talking to he led them to his
tomb please we can overcome this well
someone's unhappy with me being alive
huh
Samuel saw Olivia's a protege sponsored
her during her formal education was the
driving force behind a promotion with
global Science Council Olivia made her
fortune as one of the founders in an
instruct aerospace and defense system in
two parts things a sizeable donation
potato
Liddy's Dora Bronson Devan if Samuel
eventually offered her freedom to design
a runner on cutting-edge laboratory in
the energy business okay all right then
boink boink I know what I'm doing
apparently for some reason somehow hello
hi that's interesting baby um what's
with the sward slicing right here oh
that I needed that good more BFT stuff
for me never enough BFG ammo you asked
me oh is that a penis
what's with the babies they're trying to
clone me or something yeah I was waiting
for one of you ignoring that that
happened hell yeah a Monet I do else dad
your health if I can keep the mega off
long enough they'd be a little bit
better so this guy hmm Heelys
containment field so he was like a bad
idea to turn off containment fields
ok ha why is all this hologram except
for the face shield which is just
reflective visor oh no it's the inside
of my head [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] dude
yeah shoes and me this is what I was
talking about embedded in stone who
trapped me is a good question who put me
in there certainly it wasn't my choice
why did they just seal me away instead
of destroying me good questions all
around
boink
Wow okay is it like a Keyblade from
Kingdom Hearts or something maybe the
crucible that's what she was looking for
very good did you get the location yes
you're going to have to remove it once
you've extracted the accumulator it will
become unstable the ruptured casing
should cause a rift strong enough to
send you back to their world we can
determine your point of entry using the
tether system I uploaded to your suit
retrieving the crucible is critical
without it we have no way of shutting
down the well and closing the hell
portal here on Mars I don't get it okay
I'm gonna face that you know what you're
talking about
find out I know what they're talking
about but still how do we know that it
won't just blow me up cuz I have a funny
feeling that there's a lot of things
here that could just blow me up and I
don't like to be blown I like to do the
blowing please yep okay boink
anybody else hi my friend oh no no no no
no no no no no boy they should have sent
more than just Em's boy
oh look they sent more than just its ups
it's supposed to soon
I'm stuck on something I don't know what
though
find your big ugly face Club it's like a
needler but way cooler yeah oh [ __ ] yep
well just in time baby
hello we I'm down here now what are you
gonna do whoa yeah there we go
that you tagged adenine pack a team and
tagging I'm a day
a bit low on ammo low on ammo there we
go
add something target up yeah oh yeah
music just kicked up all of a sudden it
always seems to kick up halfway through
the battle oh my god to kill this would
be awesome well [ __ ] okay um oh there I
missed
hang on let me do it again ah [ __ ] not
direct hits well I'll send its opening
but what else isn't in my life fine
alright goodbye nice staircase
who the hell built this now why the hell
did they build it so mysteriously like
this who the hell's idea was all this
anyway the see now pop it pop it pop it
seriously stop it
[ __ ] the shield guys seriously [ __ ] the
shield guys okay so is this where
everyone went to meet about discussing
the possibilities to blow in the [ __ ]
out of the whole world oh gee oh right
in his grundle Wow uh okay well that
probably didn't kill him why are you
doing ritual sacrifices again you want
to run that by me one more time
mmm okay well one more time for good
measure better better do one more yes
one more yeah why not why not
wow that was good one now sounds really
good one is this just gonna keep going
alright you know what fine oh that was
it okay you were done there oh look nice
skull this is lovely
especially this one okay does it have a
good old time I understand long day work
you wanna kick back and relax with a few
brewskies it ain't no problem at all I
think yes okay I looked up where the
other one was I didn't know it was here
but it looked familiar so I got it and
down here oh thank you
secret goddamn secret it's just a hole
in the ground but the real secret is
over there oh boy over here cool cool
oh man this freaked me out because I was
like when I first saw this I saw that
Barrens of hell
we're strung up on the wall and that
made me go like holy [ __ ]
whatever strung these up is serious
about its business this is actually the
last level of episode two
and it is no [ __ ] joke this is where
you meet the cyberdemon and I have a
funny feeling that we're gonna be
meeting the cyberdemon relatively
quickly
Wow hi guy man yep all right let's do
whatever the hell we're doing now ribbit
do not stand below lid during gifts
during dis oh hello is that a diff okay
beam me up Scotty
yeah sorry I got scared I thought
something was coming after me
hmm okay anyway that is actually all the
time I have I'm glad I hit a checkpoint
just there but we've made a lot of
progress made a lot of mistakes too but
I'm not including we I'm saying we made
mistakes together cuz we're in this
together let's thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]